ils vivent est en isolement volontaire
depuis plus de trois décennies en
amazonie brésilienne il est décédé sans
doute de mort naturelle une photo de son
visage avait été prise en 2011 ainsi que
cette vidéo très émouvante où on le
voyait évoluer dans la forêt surnommé
l'homme aux trous car il en faisait
beaucoup pour piéger le gibier il était
issu d'une tribu qui a été décimée du
fait de la déforestation pour favoriser
l'extension des ranchs et des mines je
vais faire un billion de poissons aux
agrumes et est gérée mètres met en
corner à l'intérieur ça va muret au fur
et à mesure
c'est dégueulasse
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec des
responsables politiques que j'estime
beaucoup lionel jospin bertrand delanoë
et puis je suis aux côtés d' emmanuel
macron donc depuis 2010 elle oublié
ségolène royal oui je crois en fait oui
ce qui est terrible en fait mais c'est
que l'accusé 2 qui les gouverne ne
connaissent rien et prennent en tout
sujet les mauvaises décisions non je
vous assure que ce soit à l'école
j'étais c'est ça qui est quand même
terrible ou comprenait des politiques
dans les grosses têtes ou pas ou parce
que ça vous dérange mois sept trophées
ça vous dérange pas souleymane je
comprends pas
comprendre un tel
montant mais c'est vrai non ça me
dérange parce que je ne vois pas ce
qu'ils viennent faire je vois pas ce
qu'ils apportent mais je trouve que
c'est en quelque sorte une dégradation
de la fonction ministérielle ou pc une
dilution de ce qu'ils ont fait bon c'est
vrai qu'on plombe un peu l'ambiance et
il s'agit pas de taper de manière
caricature et caricatural et bêtement ce
gouvernement ou sur ceux qui gouvernent
la france depuis des années mais c'est
hélas un constat alors bon il ya quand
même quelques nivelles quelques belles
nouvelles j'ai essayé de les donner les
français sont de plus en plus à droite
n'ont mangé
je blague cédé pour vous fait rire ça va
bien pour eux c'est pas bien pour vous
mais je vous le dit les yeux dans les
yeux alors ça vous je n'ai pas pu m'en
fous
[Applaudissements]
j'adore tellement entendu vous savez
bien que je sois présent ou pas j'ai
aucun problème avec la liberté
d'expression et que ce soit la vôtre ou
celle de quelqu'un d'autre mais j'ai le
droit aussi de m'en [ __ ] vous étiez
pas destiné à l'humour sans qu'au
conservatoire de nom quand vous étiez le
moins drôle le
[Musique]
président ou faites attention hein sinon
moi je parle de votre choix ou encore
les étiquettes parce que je les ai piqué
6 6 6 à la fin à la pelouse à la pause
avec qu'est-ce que j'ai là il a regagné
les étiquettes de rendre le prends des
fringues et pour la télé qu'elle
remonterait en l'état à ça on et
japonisant dans la france obtenu de
taekwondo kouao bgc passe ici des alpes
ou fallait tendo
taekwondo
taekwondo wi lan art martial originaire
de corée du sud là ça fait trois là on
est ensemble n'inquiète pas il a pas
regardé ailleurs un jeu
d'une autre façon alors c'est peut être
moi non mais vraiment amoureux espagne
déficits mais c'est tout ce que je vous
souhaite même où j'essaie de garder mon
calme parce que je déteste avoir cette
position en mode mais qu'on n'est pas en
train de se battre pour un morceau de
steak qui n'est clairement pas le plus
frais du rayon et ça fait quand vous
êtes marié ou pas non on est pas qu c
est alors faudrait y penser non
passerait pas à moi de dire pas avant
nicolas
alors
je suis vraiment désolé nicolas je lui
ai laissé ma place de seconde il a déjà
foutu un rêve bernard croyable vous dire
je voudrais pas avoir une productrice
causes défendues par vous quand on est
artiste mais c'est un signe et laurence
et ben j'imagine enfin des deux s'en
fout que vous n'êtes encore productrice
de bigard jusqu'en décembre prochain je
lui souhaite pas parce que la façon dont
vous en parler car étonnant dans un
alligator tenus en laisse dans un parc à
philadelphie la vidéo cumule plus d'un
million de vues et suscite bon nombre
d'interrogations pourtant là bas tout
est normal puisque wali est un animal de
soutien émotionnel un titre officiel
obtenu il ya quatre ans par joseph pour
l'aider à surmonter sa dépression depuis
le reptile le suit partout et il est
devenu la coqueluche de son quartier si
wall y est inoffensif selon son maître
rappelons qu'aux états unis on recense
des dizaines d' attaque d'alligator par
en arrière je n'étais pas que sa
productrice j'étais aussi son agent
quand il ya des procédures justement
contre toutes les bonnes idées alors on
en a discuté et c'est jean marie qui m'a
dit christelle je suis foutu je ne
remplit plus les spectacles je ne fais
plus de stade je ne fais plus de zenit
je fais le point virgule malheureusement
je ne remplis pas encore une belle façon
les réseaux sociaux et vous avez un
petit bout d'chou g on a un fils qui va
avoir quatorze mois d'octobre déjà 14
ans ouais un fils unique il avait déjà
deux enfants de son premier mariage est
ce que vous savez que pour assurer une
retraite il faut trois enfants par foyer
c'est bon je ne vous le dis c'est fait
jean paul jean paul écoute moi j'ai fait
fox trot revenue me tutoyez pas oui je
n'ai pas bien sûr on se connaît pas mon
intention mais cette dernière on se
connait pas un oranger jamais rencontrés
avant avant ce soir mahb a annoncé un
enfant ou alors si toi ou b avec
samantha fox assure la promo
que ça a été son plateau mais je vous ai
pas vu vous voulez si on s'est vus on
avait la loge à côté
je comprends mieux kijun sen